I am mo Welch and I'm watching my conan
set it was my very first set on Conan
and it was on January 17th 2018
[Applause]
something fun about this that maybe it's
not fun if you have smellivision you
might be able to smell some pee on me
because right before I went on I dropped
the microphone into the toilet and
Torrie up and put it on and then come
out here Wow
thank you so much um this is great thank
you so much for having me you have to
say thank you at least three times if
you're going on national television I'm
a little bit surprised to be honest I
don't think I'm supposed to be a
stand-up comedian so I'm sorry like this
isn't my childhood dream my childhood
dream was to be in the WNBA the NBA for
her pleasure when I was in seventh grade
I got a women's basketball for Christmas
I immediately realized I could palmate
and I was like alright playing ball for
the rest of my life my my voice is deep
back then I also realized that I have
really large hands for a female thanks
you know what they say about a lady with
big hands gross it's funny watching it
because it feels like it's going a lot
faster and my brain and then watch and
I'm like I have a very slow cadence oh
that's a good shot of those boots I only
wore them once they were $100 I'm a
FEMINIST I've told a lot that I've
noticed a lot of people are claiming to
be feminists but I don't think you're
real feminists unless you know all of
the WNBA teams you guys want to learn
the WNBA teams I mean we're here alright
here they are la sparks in New York
Liberty Minnesota Lynx and Phoenix
Mercury Indiana Fever Dallas Wings and
San Antonio stars Connecticut Sun
Seattle storm Atlanta dreamin Chicago's
guy if you put all the teams in a
singing list you become a feminist thank
you also the Washington Mystics they
don't fit also since I've done this joke
the Las Vegas aces are now WNBA team
instead of the San Antonio Spurs I just
want to give you bad information I'm a
professional singer you guys want to
marry your mom when you were younger I
wanted to marry my mom so hard because
when you're younger adults say when you
get older you're gonna marry who you
love and I was like well I love mom
there we go
cue the wedding bells and that's a cute
and innocent thought at least it was
until my parents got a divorce it was
back on the table
[Applause]
[Music]
this is definitely a moment where I'm
like maybe I had a couple too many beers
before on stage because I'm very I said
when to walk by I'm like hey do mom say
anything about me always flirting with
me making me dinner picking me up
dropping me off my mom really does hate
that joke but I some a surprising fact
about being on Conan is that when you
walk out on stage like I had a standing
ovation because the warm-up comment was
just so good at getting everybody jazzed
up and so I walked out to a standing
ovation which I don't even ever get you
know at the end of my set so I had way
too much confidence or maybe had the
perfect amount of confidence
you'd be the not to be gay but I'm a
lesbian
thank you that's actually the first time
I've ever said that so thank you so much
but I'm gonna come out when I can get to
Burbank in front of a studio audience in
front of Conan and Andy and Molly
I'm a journalist I'm a gay and I'm Irish
and I hate parades I have a lot of gay
friends because it's required and my
friend he asked me for some advice he
was gonna come out to his 97 year old
grandma
he's like Moe are you out to your
grandparents in true story
no one's up to their grandparents the
rest is just waited out my grandparents
favorite joke I had a fun text from my
friend in the middle of the night
another friend I have two friends in
this penis yeah see straight girls I'm
just like you I get the dick pics you
have to relate to an audience you always
have to relate especially the straight
girls
he accidentally sent it to me he was
trying to send it to his girlfriend
Molly mo LLY my name is mo mo he is
lucky one more letter some people get it
you would have been sending a photo of
his poorly lit penis to M om
sure spells mom yeah can you imagine
getting that text oh it's Jeremy he
didn't forget my birthday after all
[Applause]
he was begging me he's like you have to
delete that photo off your phone I'm
like look how lesbian just keeps dick
pics on her phone but yeah like every
time he calls it shows up
[Applause]
that was it now I have that photo of me
encoded right next to my bathroom sink